- [Kelly] I love your outfit.
- Hi. Thank you, likewise.
- [Kelly] So cute. - Oh my
gosh. - [Kelly] So cute.
How are you doing?
- I'm really good. Thank you for-
- Have y'all, have you ever met?
- I, I don't wanna do the
thing of where you go like,
"Oh, like we've met before."
I don't expect you to remember
me, but we have met before.
(Kelly laughs) - Where'd we meet?
- I never do that to people
where they're like we actually met,
like I always like assume
people don't remember me.
- Me too - I had a radio show
and you came into it one time
and you gave me advice
and you were awesome.
And I told you my favorite
piece of Dr. Phil advice
that I learned early on,
and my mom like really drilled into me
and it always replays in my head is,
"How's that working for ya?"
- How's that working for ya?
- And how's that working for ya?
It's such a great thing to ask yourself.
- It is, isn't it?
- It is. - [Kelly] Yeah
- Can you ask it for me right
now? - [Kelly] I'm amaz -
- Yeah, how's that working for you?
(crowd laughing) - Oh, that felt good.
- So wait do you-
- I just screenshotted that memory.
- Do you need any advice
right now on anything?
- Actually, yes. Something just came up.
- Okay.
- [ Kelly] Okay.
- So Dr. Phil, I struggle
with like regret of like
there will be things I say, stupid things,
I'm like why did I do that? - [Kelly] Ah
- And I'll, it'll ruminate on it.
Like, for instance, like
I just told Dr. Phil
I loved him when I hugged him.
And I don't know why - (Kelly laughs)
- I said that And I wanna know what
should I do later on when I can't sleep?
Cause I'm like, why would
I say I love him to him?
Like I do but like he didn't
say it back and that's weird.
- [Kelly] You love what
he does for people.
(Everyone laughs)
- Like I just know I'm gonna
be haunted by it later.
And I, what do I do?
- [Kelly] He didn't say it back?
- Well, two things.
If I had heard it, I
would've been flattered.
- [Nikki] Awe.
(Kelly laughing)
- But I didn't hear it but
I'm glad that you said it.
- I think I whispered it,
which is even creepier.
(Everyone laughs)
- I think I tried to have
an intimate moment with you.
What am I doing?
- I love this show.
- I do too.
- But here's my advice, seriously.
- [Nikki] Okay.
- You wouldn't worry so much
about what people thought of
if you knew how seldom they did.
- Oh, that's good.
- That's good.
- Oh, that one hurts. - I mean
really we go home and obsess
about "Oh my God what
do they think about me?"
And fact is they're home sleeping.
- [Nikki] Oh my gosh - They're
home eating a chili dog.
- They don't even remember
what happened that day.
And we think they do -
- It was so yeah -
- Everybody does it. Everybody does it.
- I do that. - I love that.
- [Kelly] Yeah. - That's
really a nice reminder.
It hurts a little bit
though. - [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's kind of like when
people go, like it's none
your business, what people
think about you? - Yeah
- And you're like now I'm worried
about no one cares about me.
- [Kelly] Yeah. And now no one likes me.
(Kelly and Nikki laughs)
- Okay. Wait so did I say the
name of your show correctly?
- Yes - There's a question mark.
- Welcome Home Nikki
Glaser? - [Kelly] Glaser?
- That's how I've been saying it. - Yeah
- Yeah because its it's
about me moving from,
I was living in LA and New
York, you know, pretty much
since I graduated college and,
and living the show biz life.
And then when the pandemic hit,
I moved back home to St.
Louis to be with my parents.
- I remember you telling me that.
- I was just like I
don't have anyone else.
And I'm kind of scared right now.
And then I stayed and that's when I came
up with this idea to do a reality show.
Cause I was like, I'm
living with my parents.
They're hilarious. We
should document this.
And when, by the time E! bought the show
I had already moved out,
but I'm still living in
St. Louis. So its really me
being like, should I stay here?
Is this okay? Can I
still have a career here?
And - - Yeah.
- And just being back in
St. Louis and it's, yeah.
- Because people always have that thing
if you're living with
a parent or something
they're like, oh, either
something's wrong with your parent.
You're helping take care of them
or you're on financially, like hard times.
- Yes, or you just don't have a husband
and all of your friends -
(Kelly laughs) - Who
could live with you do.
And you're just scared -
- Or option three -
- Or you don't, you like,
I was just so scared
because stand-up went away and I do
stand-up every single night.
And I thought I did it
cause I like love it.
But really it was because I
was never wanted to be alone
with my own thoughts and like -
- And you feed off that -
- And, and feel - - Yeah. Yeah.
- I was just running from
my feelings, you get it.
(Everyone laughs) - And
so I was like, you know,
he's seen my case before.
(Kelly laughs)
And man did things get dark Dr. Phil.
When stand-up went away, I was like
I have to feel things
like, I can't just shove,
like work to me I, I can just obsess over.
So, and it was at a time
during the pandemic, I realized
I figured things out.
I got like help for
like my anxieties and -
- Yeah
- My low self-esteem and I got
to a place where I was like
I think I like accept myself.
- Well and I think it's interesting too
cause someone once said this to me too,
It's like, I wish that you
could see you how I see you.
- Yes.
- Like, because I think that
we're so hard on ourselves
and it's, and we're so
self-deprecating, it's kind
of the society's waves, our
humor, everything like that.
And so it's, it's nice if you were
I it's almost like we wish
we could see ourselves
through our friends' eyes.
- [Nikki] Yes. - You know so -
- And I was able to do that
when I, my show is currently
on E! it's it's called, you know,
Welcome Home Nikki Glaser
question mark. - [Kelly] Question mark.
And when I saw it, I
don't like to watch myself
but when I watched it, you -
- Oh, I don't either.
- When I watched it
(Nikki laughs)
- I'm fast right? I'm saying a lot.
- I feel like I've seen the whole season.
(Everyone laughs)
- I talk a lot too. I'm a lot too.
You're, you're in a good crowd
- I know -
- And I absolutely, and
I absolutely love it.
I can't not watch now.
- Okay, good. I'm so
glad. (crowd laughing)
- Seriously. - The best tease ever.
- [Nikki] Awe thanks. - Yeah
- No seriously. Isn't that great?
- Yeah. I love it. - Awe, Thank you.
- You know why? Because it's so authentic.
- Thank you. I really like, I've always -
- She doesn't lie about anything.
- I don't lie. (Kelly laughs)
- [Dr. Phil] That's what
I mean. I'm telling you.
- It was just an opportunity for me
to just really get honest and,
and hopefully have some
little, I'm honestly making TV
for myself as a little girl to be like -
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's, this isn't what you think it is -
- I think you like
communicating with people too.
You like feedback. You
like to be involved.
You like to, I, I like
that too. That connection.